Neils Bohr was a pioneer of the structure
of atom, he was from Denmark and he was given
(as far as I understand) he was given a house
by the brewery the Carlsberg brewery which
was next door to the brewery and it had a
tap in the wall which he could open and lager
would come out and it is quite an interesting
fact that during the second world war, that
Otto Hahn and Max Planck, two German Nobel
Prize winners gave Niels Bohr their Nobel
Prizes, gold medals to look after and when
Germany invaded Denmark, he was not quite
sure what he should do so his colleagues dissolved
gold in aqua regia which is a mixture of hydrochloric
and nitric acid, the only material that will
dissolve up gold and just left these beakers
of solution on the shelf and nobody realised
that it was gold and after the war the gold
was recovered and the Nobel prizes were given
back to their winners.